qué pasa con esta verdad cuál es la
verdad de la investigación que ocurre en
ayotzinapa
muchísimas gracias por el espacio soy
manuel vázquez haría lo mejor conocido
como mar garcía sobreviviente y bueno
pues como vemos han pasado ya siete años
de la tragedia desde que se llevaron a
mis compañeros hubo un período en el
cual pues trataron de manipular la
versión la verdad la investigación y la
denominaron verdad histórica de que mis
compañeros habían sido calcinados todos
en un basurero después cuando empezó
este gobierno pues dijeron que la única
verdad es que no había verdad y se
constituyeron nuevas comisiones una
fiscalía especial los expertos
internacionales estoy desearon al país
sin embargo pues no se ha avanzado
bastante sólo han sido identificados dos
más de mis compañeros las órdenes de
aprensión no se cumplimentan muchas
personas como bien lo dijiste están
siendo asesinadas y son personas claves
que vieron no estuvieron presentes
aquella noche ahora manuel usted se dice
sobreviviente de lo que pasó en una
cocina para donde estaba como cómo
ocurrieron los hechos
cómo vivió esa noche ese día usted sí en
iguala hubo muchos eventos de violencia
aquella noche yo estuve en la calle juan
n ã lvarez donde se llevaron a la
mayoría de los compañeros estudiantes
pero yo no estuve desde el principio soy
parte de una comisión que va en auxilio
después de que nos llaman los chavos de
que los están les están disparando los
policías y que tenían un muerto cuando
llegamos organizamos una rueda de prensa
y cuando estaba en la rueda de prensa
llegaron otra vez personas armadas y nos
dispararon a todos los que estábamos ahí
incluida la prensa mataron a los
compañeros se llevaron a otro lo
desarrollaron y bueno los demás corrimos
buscando auxilio para un compañero
herido en realmente pues esa esa fue mi
participación
auxiliar al compañero herido llevarlo al
hospital quedarme a cargo de los demás
heridos en el hospital
afortunadamente a mí no me alcanzó una
bala pero bueno intentaron matarnos
aquella noche manuel porque se dice que
el gobierno del ex presidente enrique
peña nieto- que estaba después a cargo
de toda esta primera investigación
mintió con el llamado el llamado caso de
la verdad histórica
porque está basado en la tortura a
muchísimos de los que tomaron presos más
de 150 personas fueron aprehendidas aquí
en aquella época la mayoría consta en
los expedientes y en sus declaraciones
de que fueron obligados a actuar si hay
un vídeo hay vídeos en los cuales se
nota a tomarse donde lució que ahora
está en israel
participando o estando presente con con
uno de los presos con una bolsa de
plástico lo están torturando entonces es
obvio que esa investigación no goza de
credibilidad además de que el grupo de
expertos internacionales
desmintió esa versión oficial porque
científicamente no pudo haber sido
posible que los 43 compañeros hubieran
sido calcinados los restos óseos recién
encontrados están deteriorados no porque
fueron sometidos al fuego sino por el
paso del tiempo entonces pues no lo no
hay forma de que sea compatible esa
verdad oficial con lo que ellos
mencionan manuel el actual presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador afirma hay
un total de 80 personas detenidas por
este caso que se sabe de estas personas
detenidas estas personas implicadas y
cómo va la investigación que además una
de las promesas del presidente de lópez
obrador fue esclarecer estos hechos que
méxico necesita saber la verdad sobre
todo los padres y madres de estas
personas asesinadas desaparecidas
singh de hecho no sólo son 80 osea
muchos de ellos han sido re aprendidos
porque durante el gobierno peña nieto se
les acusaba de delincuencia organizada
en daños a la salud portación de armas
de fuego de uso exclusivo del ejército
pero no de desaparición forzada hoy en
día está en muchas de estas personas
están acusadas por la desaparición de
mis compañeros y hay otras 40 órdenes
que todavía no se cumplimentan todavía
no hay no han dado pues con los
responsables para llevarlos a la cárcel
e iniciarle su proceso y bueno el
sexenio como bien lo mencioné se está
acabando ya vamos a la mitad de sexenio
y no hay muchos avances esperemos que
nuestros tres años hubiera pudiera haber
más avances vamos a empujar desde donde
esté pero pues nosotros nos vamos
haciendo el escenario de que pues
pudiera tardar más en el acceso a la
verdad ahora manuel que se sabe sobre
tomás perón el principal investigador de
este caso que ahora está prófugo en
israel porque huyó se están adelantando
las
las negociaciones para una posible
extradición a méxico que pueda rendir
cuentas a la justicia mexicana que dicen
en méxico sobre toma cerón no han tomó y
tomás ser aún el uso puede el arquitecto
de la verdad histórica si yo es porque
sabe cuánto cuál fue su participación en
encubrir los hechos en manipular pues la
investigación es tan irreal porque en
israel israelí méxico no tienen tratados
de extradicción entonces la fiscalía y
la secretaría de relaciones exteriores
pues están haciendo lo propio para
lograr es que tomás en un deluxe o sea
extraditado y traído a ante la justicia
mexicana esperemos que lo logren pronto
porque pues en él está la clave de
muchas cosas pues manuel y ya por último
me imagino que usted es cercano con la
familia de los 43 estudiantes
desaparecidos en la dioxina para que
dicen ellos como el estado de ánimo ya
los esperan pues siguen esperando yo sé
que nunca nunca se pierden las las
esperanzas un caso tan desgarrador como
éste pero que dicen los padres pues el
desgaste emocional físico las
enfermedades han minado ya en buena
medida su pues hizo actuar tres
familiares han sido pues fallecieron ya
en este camino
varios familiares de los compañeros
desaparecidos en la está enfermedades se
han intensificado pero el ánimo continúa
siguen unificados buscando esperando
pues que pronto haya verdad y justicia
en el caso